قافله منتظره منذ شهور شهور بالف عام في
تقويم الامهات هنا وصل الصغار اخيرا بعدما
اختفوا في ظروف الحرب واحتجزتهم روسيا
قصرا في معسكرات اعتقال وفق كييف عوده الى
اوكرانيا لحوالي 30 طفلا من روسيا الى
اوكرانيا احتجزوا خلال الحرب في روسيا
بعيدا عن اهاليهم دون القدره على التواصل
معهم وفق روايه الاطفال
لقد عمرنا مثل الحيوانات احتجزنا في مبنى
منفصل
يقولون لنا كل يوم ان والدينا رفضون واننا
غير مرغوبين
منظمه انقاذ اوكرانيا اشرفت على عمليه لم
شمل الاطفال وعودتهم الى ديارهم مهمه
معقده استمرت طويلا
الان توشك مهمه الانقاذ الخامسه على
الانتهاء سيصل 31 طفلا خلال ثلاث او اربع
ساعات لك
كان الامر خاصا ومعقدا فيما يتعلق بعدد
الاطفال الذين تمكنا من اعادتهم
قدرت كييف عدد الاطفال المختطفين في روسيا
ب
19500 طفل اوكراني منذ فبراير الماضي فيما
تواجه موسكو ادانات دوليه ضدها رغم نفيها
لجميع الادانات غذاء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات